tout de suite avec et gif erez le maire
sortant d'auxerre réélu ce soir donc
nous avons entendu votre challenger
guillaume larrivé tout à l'heure il
évoquait une campagne ordurière ces
derniers jours une campagne tout court
pour vous différence
écoutez moi j'ai connu j'ai conduit une
campagne qui est une campagne propre par
définition d'abord parce que c'est dans
la nature et j'ai toujours fait en
oeuvre en campagne électorale du plus
pur respect de mes adversaires j'ai
envie de dire à guillaume larrivé que
quand on est perdant on doit être grand
seigneur c'est la règle en la matière
comment vous expliquez vous que vous
ayez réussi à résister à cette vague de
dans le pays parce que vous allez y en a
eu le vent du boulet comme on disait
tout à l'heure c'est très juste cette
victoire le vent du boulet gelé senti
gelé senti ces derniers mois je l' ai
senti ces dernières semaines mais je
crois et je rebondis sur ce que disait
bernard moraine lorsque les choses vont
mal il reste quelques points de repères
et auxerre est resté sous la conduite
est resté d'une certaine manière un
repère pour les auxerrois c'est le
travail quotidien c'est le travail de
tous les jours et c'est aussi cette
capacité je crois tout simplement
entendre à écouter et dans un contexte
national qui est n'écoute pas
visiblement suffisamment et bien à
travers ce qu'on me dit il ya beaucoup
de villes perdues aujourd'hui par les
socialistes bourgogne je crois que dijon
et auxerre ont résisté et bien tant
mieux c'est une qualité des mères qui
dirige cette ville ces villes